frédéric aiguille bonjour vous êtes donc
journaliste à la rédaction du web du rt
france vous vous penchez sur le dossier
des élections américaines alors à les
grands électeurs américains ont voté un
le 14 décembre dernier ils ont décidé
eux ils ont désigné le candidat
démocrate joe biden comme vainqueur de
la présidentielle pourtant donald trump
pour le disait n'a toujours pas concédé
sa défaite à espère t-il vraiment
pouvoir changer la donne alors en effet
donald trump l'a dit et l'a répété il ne
concédera pas estivants de cette
élection a été marqué par une fraude
massive où lui et son équipe juridique
ont expliqué à de maintes reprises
qu'ils épuiserait tous les moyens à leur
disposition pour inverser le résultat
et pour ce faire le président dispose
encore de plusieurs options il faut tout
d'abord noter que le vote du collège
électoral le vote des grands électeurs
n'est pas encore officiel il ne peut il
ne le deviendra parlons que le 6 janvier
lorsque le congrès se réunira sous
l'autorité du vice président mike pence
pour ouvrir et comptabilisés les
bulletins or à ce moment là le vote peut
être contestée par le congrès même si le
patron des sénateurs républicains mitch
mcconnell appelé son camp à ne pas se
résoudre à une telle option
rien ne dit qu'il sera écouté et pour
cause l'élu républicain de l'alabama mot
brooks a d'ores et déjà publiquement
fait connaître son intention de
contester le résultat du vote
frédéric que se passerait-il dans ce cas
de figure
et bien si un sénateur et un élu de la
chambre des représentants conteste le
résultat
le congé alors l'obligation de se réunir
en session extraordinaire deux heures
durant pour discuter de la légitimité de
cette objection les deux chambres votre
et ensuite séparément pour soit acceptée
soit rejeté cette objection
et si les deux chambres la retiennent on
se dirigerait vers ce qu'on appelle une
élection contingentes c'est à dire qu'il
reviendrait à la chambre des
représentants et non plus aux grands
électeurs d'élire le prochain président
américain et ses votes se ferait selon
un système particulier d'un vote par
état c'est à dire que même si les
démocrates sont actuellement davantage
d'élus à la chambre des représentants
les républicains qui dominent en termes
de délégation c'est à dire que ce qui
signifie qu'en tel vote
il suivait des lignes partisanes serait
en fait favorable à d'autres est-ce que
ce scénario est probable alors donc en
l'état actuel des choses c'est un cas de
figure hautement improbable pour
convaincre la chambre des représentants
qui est à majorité démocrate de prendre
en considération de valider une
éventuelle et aux objections
il faudrait que le compteur que le
contraintes pardon parviennent à prouver
à de manière sans l'ombre d'un doute
possible qu'ils aient une fraudes ou des
irrégularités à grande échelle à même
d'influer sur le résultat des élections
est pour le moment le camp entre up n'a
pas réussi à prouver qu'il y avait eu
des irrégularités à grande échelle lors
de cette élection alors dont la cour
suprême a déjà rejeté les recours qui
visaient à invalider les résultats
électoraux dans plusieurs états clefs
pour autant donald trump n'a peut-être
pas encore dévoilé tout son jeu
récemment le président a fait référence
à un piratage de grande envergure qui a
frappe qui a frappé solarwinds cela wine
c'est une entreprise qui fournit un
logiciel informatique plusieurs agences
gouvernementales américaines
et à propos de ce piratage le chef
d'état un message quelque peu sibyllin
insinuer qu une puissance étrangère il a
évoqué directement la chine avait
peut-être interférer dans l'élection
présidentielle le directeur du
renseignement national doit remettre à
donald trump dans les jours à venir
un rapport sur cette question si dans ce
rapport une telles interférences venait
d'approuver le chef d'état pourrait
alors appliquer un décret signé en
septembre 2018 qui donne une grande
latitude et qui lui permet notamment de
nommer un procureur spécial pour
enquêter sur cette supposée
interférences le cas échéant il serait
difficile d'imaginer que cela n'ait
aucun impact sur la fameuse session du
congrès du 6 janvier prochain voire même
plus tard c'est en tout cas cette
éventualité que se rattache désormais
principalement les partisans de donald
trump qui espère que cette élection
décidément chaotique réserve encore des
surprises
merci beaucoup frédéric et guy le
rappelle on peut vous lire sur notre
site
rt france point tv frédéric aiguille
journaliste à la rédaction du web de rt
france